so we've got today tomorrow a small rest day on
monday but next week i mean i don't no point in
looking ahead we've got a crazy day here today
and you know what's hilarious something just
fell from the roof of this building and hit
my camera i'm going to school hi everybody
why is danny going out of frame i know you
want me all right i told you the main host
you don't need to do it this much sound proofing
sound moving from the ceiling so the new studio we
have here is actually not complete yet we've been
doing all kinds of stuff and what you just saw
you can't fake um hey buddy are you gonna don't
shake your head at me like this is on me buddy
all right anna this is it you got two of your
students pokey and rubius the xqc of of uh of
spain they call him that is that
is that a fair nickname i think
excuse the canadian rubies i must say rubius
was there before i'm gonna defend himself
he himself memes about it he himself screams
about that so it's all right but yeah my heart is
absolutely torn and i work with both of them very
closely i i have five students in pakistan but
these are the two students that i have been
working the most closely with so i especially
am nervous for both of them and how well they do
and i just wish they could both win the match but
obviously that's not possible so i just want them
to do their best as if they were my two kids and
made a better player win this is going to be hard
i mean the the queen is unattacked the knight
is pinned he kind of has to find the move queen
e6 here i think so and i was worried that if he
chooses the d6 square which looks like a natural
choice but this runs into a discovered attack
knight takes c6 it was so difficult to react
to knight e5 i think pocky showed a brilliant
preparation bishop b595 kind of refutes my setup
because i didn't expect such an aggressive setup
um by white in the london it's usually c3 and
everything is very calm but no bishop b5 and 95
immediately pointing out that the knight on
c6 and the queen on d7 could get into trouble
well and now we see we see pokey executing
perfectly the point everybody is after knight
takes c6 the queen is under attack and she's
winning a piece of piece like you're doing it
it's the first time that that
someone plays this against him
he's currently talking about
the virgin mary i believe
so moment of truth right now will she see rook c7
pocky absolutely loves puzzles she she
has been on the puzzle grind from the
very beginning so i wouldn't be surprised
if she spots some of those tactical patterns
kings because he wants to
escape to a7 but he doesn't see
she found the best move discover check
and ruby start he could take the rook but
the bishop on g3 is the killer piece you
saw him try to take the rook with the
bishop he physically grabbed it it was like
what the heck is going on here oh my gosh
look at rubius rook c1 threatening rook b1 oh my
gosh he's setting up a last minute mating trap
okay holy bejesus snaps bucky needs to find a
way to get some space for her king and moving
up one square uh could be a way actually oh but
no if she has matey one she has made him one she
also has mating one if she had taken on a6 but
that was really hidden instead she just she just
created some space for her king now this is this
is of course brilliant too because now she can run
away with the king so even though she didn't see
the mate um it still is checkmate on a6 but it's
quite a hidden checkmate she was thinking more
of the safety of her kid i think now she realizes
i was thinking about the safety of her king i
didn't even see she had maiden one um i wasn't
looking okay wow i'll i think she will get it now
bishop before was a brilliant way to free the king
two queens versus two rooks should be should
be good enough now the e8 rook is hanging
and also a6 that pawn on a6 has been the hidden
threat for the last couple of moves i wonder if
she will spot it now or will she give queen d4
check which is also a strong move queen classy
that's a grand master play when you're
winning to just get rid of your opponent's
pieces because you no longer care if it's an
equal trade just get them off the board so
again it's not made in one but if you're watching
as a fan and a viewer who wants to get better
that is a very human grand master thing to do and
uh applause is for for pokey or deserve for that
this is trying to run with the pawn okay
is still made no i don't want to draw sir
did ruby suffer a draw um oh ruby has
offered to draw the chess.com chat hilarious
i was wondering what happened there of course
pocky refuses i think that was a joke from rubio's
side i can't even hear what he's saying
but i'm reading his lips and he's staying
styled muscles tables tables
avocados trying to get the stalemate
the problem is she's playing against
someone who knows a trick pocky taught
me that the queen should be a night shadow away
so the shadow of the night is right now on ca
you know
wow stables fables unbelievable
what a roller coaster here we go with the
french and they're playing principled moves
even if they're not the theoretically
best moves in the french right because
you could argue okay if a grandmaster sat down was
playing white here they might they might be able
to do some damage and they'd probably look to open
the center and kind of uh punish black there but
but also it doesn't mean what pokey's doing is
wrong we know c5 is the idea usually it comes
after an e5 advance to undermine this d-pawn
that's kind of the risk is does rubius realize
that this isn't a normal french
and that he might have an option
just kind of blow things open right
now i'd be curious to see what he does
i wonder if he's considering those moves he
plays bishop to a4 which may create tactical
opportunities for pokey because now the knight on
c3 has too many things to do has to be guarding
the bishop and also has to be guarding the e4
pawn yeah i think [ __ ] spotting it captures
immediately yeah she doesn't have to be asked
why she takes it now will she see she can even
take with the knight here now because she unpinned
the uh the knight to the queen this would be okay
both are good in fact actually pawn takes is
probably even better i just thought knight
takes might have really really shown that she
understood uh the power of bishop e7 but maybe
this is even better now she can win the d-pawn
and just wow pokey pokey main pokey the beast
yeah i think she will castle she she does know
her opening principles very well um if she doesn't
castle it will be because she spots a tactical
pattern but yeah makes perfect sense to castle
and now for rubius some of the ideas could be
to chase that knight away from d4 because it's
a very strong piece for pocky or try to bring
the knight back from a4 because it's a bit of a
sad piece on the edge of the board pokey needs to
be a bit careful here because queen b3 does set up
a threat the knight on c6 can be undermined by the
capture on c6 and then the bishop on b4 is hanging
so i wonder if she will move the bishop away or
will she spot that she could place that knight on
d4 because there's a night fork on e2 but that's
a bit that's a bit too much way too dang oh a6
oh a6 didn't didn't guard the bishop but now
rugby won instantly by rubio so pocky has a chance
to defend the bishop with the queen queen e7
or queen a5 what's that tough position for him
on trading and simplifying now and it doesn't mean
she may not see pc five minutes right now but but
i think overall she's had a mission and she's been
sticking to it i'm up a bunch of pollens and i'm
going to trade peace i think she sees it i think
she's just making sure whether it's a bishop or
queen check that's better because now the knight
is hanging and the e5 bishop too is in the air
he is on fire and improving by the by the
day anybody watching this should be be
afraid of pokeman be very afraid she is he is
getting better at chess it's absolutely smooth
sailing she takes the bishop on e5 and now she's
threatening bishop to c5 and i'm sure she sees it
i'm sure she sees it because her grind oh knight
to d7 hence the night he brushes her shoulder off
no no big deal like instantly took that night
like instantly no problem wow yeah rubius was
rubios was drawing us an arrow to the
c5 square i thought on on his stream so
what does that mean she's saying with the i
don't speak fluent coolness i think that was a w
i'm always afraid i'm going to make
an inadvertent inappropriate sign
that means something and so i don't i
don't like to make signs with my hands
it doesn't go well maybe ruby
is offered a joe again oh
going nuts with it lmao
i think she will spot it again
she has been on the puzzle grind
ever since she started practicing chess so
what's he saying
screw
because he's saying that he's gonna get one of
the pieces for free that he can take either the
d7 knight or the b4 bishop so he doesn't
see that it's checkmate here for pocky and
i don't think she sees it just yet either
because she would have played it already by now
shout out to mark 100 net with the 100 donation
just now we love you mark you're helping us reach
that goal i think we're going to get there
before the day's over okay thank you so much
everyone for the contribution she defends the
bishop on b4 allowing queen takes d7 but then
bishop c5 queen f1 will be chat meeting
too i think this is what she has set up
yeah i'm sh i'm sure she sees it
here we go here we go only move
boom so rather than going for the maiden one
she goes for the five head play of matin two
even harder exactly exactly no draw he keeps off
i think they might be a little biased
there might be a ruby's fan lurking there
nada nada i think that means nothing i
don't speak spanish but i did statements
we went to this moment here in
this first game where you played b4
and we were talking about how while this is a
dangerous pawn it could be one that backfires
if you recognize the c file how early did you
realize that even though you lost this pawn
that the game was not over and that you had a
chance to make a comeback here with this tactic
to be completely honest um pawn pushes are
a weakness of mine for sure so i was kind of
you know i was feeling myself i was like let's do
it and immediately after i was like oh no he has
check oh no i block with my queen oh no he has my
rook and i was this close to resigning so close so
close you didn't you didn't taught me don't resign
um you know uh forget what the teacher said in
in a queen's gambit just keep playing so i kept
playing and i got really lucky with the uh with
the discover check and finding a tactic there so
yeah it was kind of just i i felt bad i felt bad
if i resigned there but if you asked me for a draw
in that moment i would have accepted immediately
immediately why didn't you accept my draws they
weren't there yeah you offered them just a little
too late i'm like mating too and you're like draw
draw yeah it was fair and ruby is what what were
you thinking here because and it is a good lesson
for future games right you won the rook you took
pokey's rook um but you decided to keep the queens
on the board and is it because you just you get
nervous with the queens being traded or were you
were you not realizing how big your advantage
was if you had traded queens um no i i think
it is the the second thing yeah i always feel
like and that's something i have to learn that i
sometimes have to to trade queens right because uh
if not uh yeah the game goes very bad for me like
like this one but one thing i want to say is that
the the most amazing thing about these two matches
with poki were the openings her pawn openings
it was like suddenly i had like uh zero pounds
and she had taken and almost all of my pawns in
the second game i don't know how she did it like
nice it took me like three minutes to realize
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm taking full full
responsibility because i think i prepared very
very complex openings for you and
pocky knows her lines very well so she
she has been practicing the london and the
french defense and even if even if i show
you a line she will still have more experience in
it so for next time i will know i need to go for
something simpler where we we keep our pawns
safe but i was in such a difficult spot and
danny knows like i spent the whole match being
nervous for both of you i wanted both of you
to do your best and i wish you could both win um
but ruby is something that i mentioned something
anna is so sweet and cute for my match against
xqc she sent me two videos that are like ten plus
minutes longer call me two okay these are some
things to remember wait she's saying yeah yeah
and then against rubius she was like three minutes
hey listen i love you guys both and i care about
you both and i hope you both win and i'm sorry
but like i'm just watching you and i don't know
what to do and i hope you can get it yeah she
said something i was like you're so nice yeah
she's amazing anna's amazing the best teacher
we could have absolutely we we've known that
anna's the biggest sweetheart in the
chest we've known that secret for a
while but now the rest of the streaming
community is figuring it out she really is
and i her coaching is evident pokey you said
in that moment when you won you were just being
honest you were like i didn't think i was
going to win a match this whole tournament
yeah now not only have you won one you might
be one of the favorites to move on to the
championship bracket i mean how are you feeling
about your chess right now um i kind of just
put myself into this mindset of i'm here for a
good time and so as long as the matches are fun
i hope it's a fun viewing experience for everyone
and if that's the case then i'm happy so in that
sense you know less nerves and just hoping for the
best yeah and rubios i was going to tell you that
um i didn't want to tell you how the group stage
is going but um you want a rematch against sqc
and this is your chance pocky is your ticket to
a potential rematch because if pocky beats xqc
today at the end of the day they're gonna play
today then pocky is going to the championship
bracket and you go to the same bracket as xqc
so i know you're not happy about the result
no no no do you remember the video i sent you
about xqc drawing the bracket you are going to
that birthday yeah yeah yeah okay yeah that was if
i won today okay no no no no no it didn't matter
for you it didn't matter what you do but because
pocky won she can also win against xqc and then
xqc and you go to the same part of the bracket
and that's what you want because you want to prove
that you are the og you're the real rubios he is
copying you right that's what we need to prove
by the chess moves you make on the board exactly
that's the plan yes yes yes you can play against
him in the finals it's still possible oh cool
okay pokey you have to kick his ass today okay
i'll do my best i'll do my best all right well
uh thank you both again for an awesome match and
great interviews pokey good luck we'll see you
i guess in a couple hours and and ruby is have
a great day and and best of luck in maybe your
future rematch versus xqc yeah thank you both